- The television
commercial as you and I sit
and have this discussion right
now is fundamentally over.
(upbeat music)
The GaryVee Audio Experience.
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Hope everybody's doing super well.
I haven't done a interview on the podcast
in quite a long time,
and I'm extremely excited
to be doing so here today.
Today we have a gentleman on the show
who is a marketer.
I admire quite a bit from afar,
and recently we've
gotten to know each other
and the timing was perfect
because he's got a new book out.
And honestly, I've been talking a lot
about entrepreneurship.
I've been talking a lot about culture
and I felt like I just really wanted
to get into a little bit of depths
of marketing on the podcast.
And I couldn't think of
a better person than Raja
and the timing of his incredible new book.
So Raja visually, 'cause
I know a lot of people
are listening, but people
will also watch this.
Visually, why don't you
hold up your book cover?
I've had the feeling of having the book.
So I know it's like having a
child, so it's fun to show off
- With absolute pleasure.
(Raja and Gary laughing)
Here is my book and I
feel so good about it.
- Very good Raja,
why don't you tell everybody who you are,
your name, what you do
and the book you just wrote
and why you wrote the book
and then we'll get into it.
- Terrific, so, my name is Raja Rajamannar
and I'm the chief marketing
and communications officer for Mastercard.
I'm also the president of
Mastercard's healthcare business.
And I've been in the field
of marketing for more than 35 years now.
And I have seen a lot of changes
over this period of time
and having served both on
the business management side,
in addition to being on
the functional management
of marketing, I have been able
to get perspectives from different angles.
And as I see right now,
we are at the verge
of an unprecedented level of disruption
as far as marketing goes,
predominantly led by technologies
that are coming at us like a Tsunami,
new technologies coming
at us like a Tsunami.
The current ways of doing marketing,
the current strategies
and the current frameworks
of marketing will completely
collapse immediately.
We need to reinvent and rethink marketing.
And my whole book called
"Quantum Marketing"
exactly does that.
It says what these new technologies are,
what the new data capabilities are,
what the cultural shifts are,
and how is it going to impact marketing
in ways that were absolutely
we could not imagine.
And therefore what the solution should be.
How do you look at every
aspect of marketing?
Like whether it is loyalty or advertising
or consumer insights, be it
which are a part of the ecosystem
or the processes of marketing,
how do you read with it?
So I'm challenging a lot
of our existing, you know
theories and concepts around marketing
and I'm seeing they are totally useless
at this point in time,
as we are just entering the fifth paradigm
that that's what I call
the new phase of marketing
where all these disruptions are happening
and how marketers can be successful.
So this book, Gary is a little bit
like a playbook at a very high level
for the marketing folks
across all the levels, right?
From the CMO down
to somebody who's just beginning
their career in marketing.
It's because I kept, I
simplified it so much
and demystified the whole thing
that people will really
have fun reading it.
And it could be inspiring
as much as it is daunting.
- Raja, on the daunting
part, obviously, you know
I'm listening to you and I'm
like, "Ooh, this is good."
Because, you know, as you know,
I'm a human and a company
in the marketing ecosystem
that is speaking to,
"Hey, the way we've been doing this
is very vulnerable."
So I'm curious, in detail
what is one of the
biggest vulnerabilities?
I mean, you know, you just
made such an important
powerful statement that,
hey, the way we've been marketing
is about to get massively disrupted.
And honestly, I think
we probably both agree
with this and it's why you
probably wrote it down.
It's already been disrupted
yet the actions are lagging behind.
In your opinion,
maybe one or two scenarios
where that has happened
where do you think the
conventional marketing
industry is bullish on something
and you're like, "No, my friends
in the framework of quantum
like this is a problem
and we need to have
this honest discussion.
- Yeah, so Gary in fact
you're absolutely right
that all the disruptions have happened.
But my assertion is that,
the disruption we have seen is nothing.
If you look at any shift in the past
it was predominantly a
couple of technologies.
Like when we moved from
paradigm one to paradigm three
it was just radio and
television in a big way.
Two to three was data
analytics and internet.
Three to four is social
media and mobile devices.
No two technologies in each stage.
But now we're getting more
than two dozen technologies
which are coming at us
like artificial intelligence,
augmented reality, virtual
reality, wearables,
smart speakers, internet
of things, autonomous cars.
It's like a breathless
number of technologies
which are coming our way.
And we are totally unprepared
as a marketing community and as companies
as to how we are going to
navigate that brave new future.
So this is number one.
Number two, when you look
at some of the areas,
like if you look at loyalty as an example.
We spend hundreds of billions with a B
hundreds of billions of dollars every year
on loyalty programs.
Now, if I look at some interesting Pavlos
in people's real lives,
a BBC survey, which I came
across, had said that,
it was actually, the
survey was not done by BBC,
but it was on bbc.com.
They said that, more
than 70% of the people
in a relationship either
marriage or live-in relationship
have admitted to have
cheated on their partners.
This is in spite of the fact
that there is an explicit
or an implicit commitment
with the managed contract
or legal contract or religious
mantras, whatever it is.
And they have consequences
if they are found straying.
The consequences could
be financial damage,
reputational damage, emotional hurt
for the people they cared about and so on.
In spite of the commitment
and the consequences
people, anyway, strict, they're not lying.
Now I'm saying, as
marketers, obvious stupid
in assuming that people will be loyal
to our brands when they are not loyal
in their own personal lives.
- I love that.
- Right, and look at
the second aspect of it,
which is--
- Real quick, I'm sorry to interrupt you.
The sheer Delta in one's appreciation
to their spouse or
partner versus to a coffee
or a credit card or a
sneaker is laughable.
- Exactly, you said it right.
in fact I just tried to put hierarchy
for people in terms of what is
important in people's lives.
What is the level of
loyalty or absence of it
and commercial transactions are way below.
There is no concept of loyalty there.
So how do you really think about it?
So this is one part of it.
Look at the other way round.
When I grew up in India,
like in most of the British
Commonwealth countries,
there are and all those posters
which used to be kept behind
the cashier in a shop.
It says the customer is a King or queen.
The question is, if customer
is truly the King or queen,
is the King loyal to his or her subjects,
or the lot the subjects
should be loyal to the King or the queen.
So which means, are
brands going to be loyal
or should be loyal to
their clients or customers,
or are customers expected to be loyal?
So we got the equation wrong,
because as brands, while
we say the customer,
we are in the service of the customer,
we expect customers to be loyal to us.
That's a complete, we got it wrong
in terms of the entire perspective.
- I mean, I'm sorry to interrupt.
The shock, that would
be the word I would use.
The shock, that I was met with,
in my own body 13 years ago, 12 years ago
when I entered the major industry
field, Fortune 5,000 land
with my company, VaynerMedia was,
on a good day companies
considered the customer.
On a normal day, they
spent 100% of their energy
on their P&L, and the CFO
actually ran the company.
I've never seen anything like it.
I come from CEO land and I am probably
more chief heart officer call it HR,
customer service rep.
I literally lived my whole life customer,
the way I built both my companies,
my families and mine was
employee, customer, me.
My dad, immigrant businesses, you know,
the business is the third child.
So you feed it
and you don't take money out
of it and buy a boat, you know?
And so, the least consumer centric thing
I've ever seen in my life,
is Fortune 500 companies.
Period.
- See, the irony Gary is
you call it customer service
which means you're the
service of the customer.
So who should be loyal to whom?
Think about--
- A hundred percent
I laugh when people are like
our customers are not brand loyal to us.
I'm like, they're not your customers.
See, this is an interesting
point, Raja, right?
Right, the audacity,
the, what is it, slavery?
The audacity that because
they've tried your service
or have used it for four years
or buy your product, you know
just audacity
and for granted that
people take, you know?
Listen coming from your
industry when you have,
let's talk or we can talk Colas.
'Cause I don't, I'll use Cola
even though I think your industry
and credit card has a similar dynamic,
'cause you have two or
three or four leaders,
but let's use Cola.
But the reason I like the
credit card industry is,
in the face of cryptocurrency,
in the face of new dynamics,
things change and people lose
'cause they take it for granted.
And when they're taking it for granted,
inevitably there's underlining resentment,
unconscious resentment at
the scale, at the consumer.
And they are prepared to act on it
when given the alternative.
- So totally right.
In fact, at all,
that's the whole thing.
The mindset with which we have to approach
has dramatically changed, right?
Now, loyalty is, for example,
I'm saying we have to reinvent loyalty.
We should actually talk about
preference management, right.
And preference management at every stage
or every time the consumer
has to make a decision.
How does the brand show up
and influence the choice
in favor of itself?
That's what the whole mandate
would be going forward
as opposed to saying, I win the consumer
the consumer is loyal to me, et cetera,
that has to evolve.
Likewise, I'm saying advertising, right?
Now as a consumer, as
an ordinary human being,
do I like advertisements?
Maybe for a short time during Super Bowl
just to see (indistinct)
that's a cultural moment.
But otherwise advertisements
are an absolute nuisance,
they are an interruption to my experience.
Now we talk of consumer experience design,
seamlessness, frictionlessness,
and here we are
when I'm watching a
YouTube video, for example
on some animals or what it could be.
Every three minutes annoyingly,
there is an interruption.
Now I'm reacting as a consumer,
as a normal human being.
I hate them.
At that time I'm just waiting.
When will that skip button, will come up
so I can click on it.
I'm not engaged with that ad
and to make my life more difficult
they want me to suffer
through two advertisements.
Not when there's a one
by two and two by two.
Like you know, this is total--
- And it's, by the way, I love this.
This is exciting me to no end.
They literally, when they went to digital,
they literally made the
little X on the phone
for you to click out, so small
that you would by accident, hit the...
how do people not understand,
back home Raja at the math labs
and the media companies
and the analytics teams.
Everyone's high-fiving, look
at the click-through rate.
In real life, when I miss it
and I can't click it, I
literally look and I'm like,
"I will never buy a Toyota in my life.
I will never..."
Like I get mad.
Like intent matters.
And it is very clear
when we create that level
of friction for the consumer
to trick them into...
It's like kidnapping my attention.
- Exactly, without your permission
or without you feeling
good about it, right?
Look at this way, Gary, on the one hand
we are interrupting them so bad.
The consumer are
therefore reacting, right?
There are estimates anywhere
between 600 million and 2.2 billion people
have installed ad blockers.
Predominantly in Asia,
it's growing like there is no tomorrow.
600 million it's at scale.
You're talking about 10%
plus of your population
in the world, or almost 10%, one.
Number two, they're going
to add free environment
of paying money.
For example, YouTube
itself gives you an option
to have ad free by paying
$12 or $13 every month.
- Correct.
- So people are running away--
- Look what's what's happening
with the biggest medium in modern history,
around advertising, the television.
The television commercial as you and I sit
and have this discussion right
now is fundamentally over.
And what I mean by that,
the growth of OTT in the last
five years is staggering.
Netflix is the dominant
players, Euro commercials
the procure point to your point
something that people did
not think was gonna happen.
The premium version of
the ad supported companies
the Hulu's of the world,
growing 'cause people value
time and they say to themselves,
"Wait a minute, let me get this right."
Even acting income levels
that may not seem obvious.
"Let me get this right.
I can pay $20 a month and
not lose these two minutes
every time I watch something or I can..."
And they are choosing
even with restrictive
average incomes that you would...
Similar to Uber.
I passed an Uber
famously to my community
twice in the angel round,
but I invested in it a little bit later
because I couldn't believe
who was using an Uber.
I was like, "These people can afford this?
Wait a minute, convenience
is always going to be King."
And in New York, waiting for yellow cab
for two minutes is still worse
than still being in the
coffee shop, hitting the Uber.
And even all, I'm paying
$21 and I can't afford it.
I'm choosing convenience
and lack of friction
and time so I can afford it actually.
And that's what we're
gonna see in advertising.
People are gonna pay for the premium stuff
and the ads are gonna go slowly but surely
into a place where they're
gonna struggle to be consumed.
And then what you see in Super Bowl,
where they're very expensive is,
it's a hobby to watch it.
The company step up their game
from an entertainment level
hence the celebrities and the creativity.
And I think that Super Bowl
like DNA is gonna trickle
into every single piece of content
they put out in the world,
not at the same expense
but the effort and the lack of audacity
and the effort to try to bring value.
- Absolutely, and in fact,
that's exactly what I say
in my book which is,
"Advertising, as we know, is dead."
We have to completely
reframe, rethink advertising
and how do we go about it, right?
And so each one of these, you know
kind of areas I'm asking
in a very provocative way
and I'm not just stopping at asking
but I'm also trying to give
some suggested solutions
or approaches, which are
obviously not comprehensive.
People have to keep thinking
about different ways
of solving the issue and
accomplishing their objectives.
But this is what broadly I'm approaching
as far as the book is concerned.
And I feel so excited
that finally it has been printed
and it's out to the market
on the 9th of February.
- I love it.
What, let's bounce
around here a little bit
more about you, how,
somebody who's listening,
how did your career in marketing start?
You know, what kind of kid were you,
were you more art, were you more math?
Little, you know
little inspiration and maybe
pattern recognition for,
or blueprint for some of the audience.
How'd you get to this
point in your career,
or to even bring more value?
You know, what are the common
themes that you've seen
from others and your contemporaries
that have gotten them
to the place of CMO ship,
which I think a lot of people
who are listening right
now actually aspire to be.
- So I would say in my own case, Gary
I started studying chemical engineering.
And so I'm a data and a quantitative guy
to start with at the core.
That's been my training.
When I went to MBA, I wanted to specialize
in environmental management
about pollution control
and how to keep the world green and so on.
So I had that sense of purpose
and therefore I was
pursuing in that direction.
But something happened
during the internship.
When I was doing my summer internship,
I overheard a conversation
in the company was working
about some advertisement
they were creating,
to make cosmetics, color cosmetics
more acceptable to people,
particularly for the conservative
backgrounds in South India.
So I said, "Why are these
guy's missing the point?
It should be so simple."
And I just created an ad in five minutes.
And I said, "Is it bad to look good?"
Was the headline.
And I just put the sketch.
And I said, "Hey, what do
you guys think about it?"
And they were zapped, "This
is absolutely awesome."
And they said, "This is brilliant."
And actually they created
the campaign off that,
and it went on to become a hit.
So, suddenly when you get
that kind of early success--
- Yeah, when you get that affirmation.
- Skill is I quickly started
taking marketing classes
in the second year in specialization
and I started totally enjoying it.
So since then, I have been--
- I'm sorry to interrupt you.
I want everybody to hear this
'cause I'm always thinking
about the audience.
Back to the whole point
of this conversation.
Putting yourself in
positions for serendipity
is an incredibly
underestimated aspect of life.
And when I hear that story
I think about the other
places that he applied
that Raja applied for internships.
I think about why he
even got that internship.
You know, I think about why he was even
in that hall, but being aware,
this is where I'm going
a little bit different
to make him really important.
Being open to opportunity at all times
is an incredible skillset and
something I believe in, Raja.
- Absolutely, and I
couldn't have articulated
really better at all.
It's so true.
And because all along for seven years
I was pursuing the direction
of environmental management
and I just flexed
into this pivoted to marketing.
Also interesting to what I did was,
I changed quite a few companies.
Now it is going by the
standards of my day.
I worked at a company where I
started a marketing department
and learned the hard way.
I was the junior flunky
in a three people marketing department.
Again, we produced award-winning ads
and the logistics solutions
new kind of pricing models,
new kind of packaging.
I had real fun.
And when I was awarded at that time
the marketer of the year,
Unilever picked me up
and I moved to Unilever.
Where I had to unlearn some of the things
that I have wrongly assumed
and learn things in a
more classical grounded
kind of profession and
understand structured processes
without losing the entrepreneurial spirit
of my previous--
- Well, let's go to this.
'Cause I know a lot of marketers
are gonna be listening.
Do you feel like a lot
of marketers need to now
unlearn the things that the Unilevers
and Proctors and others had taught?
- I think so.
- Yeah.
I do too.
Yeah, go ahead.
- But the frameworks you have been taught
or they have learnt on
themselves are collapsing.
That you have to absolutely relearn
and you have to unlearn some of the stuff
that you have actually
picked up along the way.
So that's one thing.
The other thing I would say is,
I've always been very open to a move.
So in fact, one of my biggest shocks
and this is a big lesson
for me in my life is,
when I joined Unilever,
at that time, the head
of marketing said that,
"You have to start your career
in sales, not in marketing."
I said, "Why should I be in sales?"
Because I thought sales was
for the less intelligent,
less creative people, only
gifted with the gift of gab.
So he said,
"No, you need to understand
what it means to sell."
Believe me, I hated the first
few weeks of doing sales
but then slowly I started appreciating it.
And over a period of time I realized,
marketing in isolation is fluffy.
- Correct.
- You need to be able to connect the dots
to either sales or business outcomes.
Or else what's the purpose of marketing?
- I'll be honest with you.
This is my biggest
problem in this ecosystem.
I'm a marketer and a brand man
but the sheer lack of connection
to reality in the creative
marketing industry is ludicrous
and tone deaf and
actually grossly negligent
by most brand people and
creative agencies, period.
- I totally agree.
And I think that's one of
the reasons why I keep saying
that marketing isn't an
existential crisis precisely
for that reason.
Because we have as
marketers isolated ourselves
in these you know, bubbles
remarketing for marketing sake,
and then not really mainstreaming
ourselves and companies
so much so that there are studies now
which are showing that the bulk of CEOs
don't have faith and trust in
their marketing departments
as business drivers.
They're eliminating the roles of CMOs,
they're fragmenting marketing,
distributing marketing responsibilities
outside of marketing.
And so--
- Raja, are you anticipating discomfort
from your peers when they read this?
Because it sounds like
you're gonna be poking
at the golden goose,
like the establishment of that.
Have you given it to some
friends in this industry?
I mean, you know, this sounds like,
listen, I'm getting excited by the second.
I wasn't, you know, me, I don't,
I go in pretty improv,
so I didn't have a full sense of...
I had a good sense of you
and you were thoughtful.
So I said yes, to do the podcast.
I don't think I really understood from it.
It sounds like a different angle
and clearly a very different demeanor
and tone and energy,
but it seems like you're
gonna be poking at something
that has caused a lot of people
to be anxious about my communication,
that style of what I actually say,
are you anticipating that?
And have you had people read
it yet or to look at it?
Yeah, please
- In fact I realized I
was going to poke the bear
in a big way, right?
And I wanted to make sure firstly,
because I'm doing it
I had to cover all my,
what do you call logic?
My data support and my examples
and everything had to
be perfectly prepared--
- Correct.
- Which I spent some time
to really do that well.
Second, I ran this manuscript
past some of my peers.
Like the CMO Unilever, CMO of Microsoft
of IBM, of General Mills, et cetera.
And I was so delighted
whether it is a classical
company of those sorts
which I just listed out
or the contemporary ones
like the Facebook and Twitter
their CMOs, et cetera.
I have gone through that.
I went to professors at Howard
and Yale asked them to review.
And I went to matter,
subject matter experts
and company areas like
blockchain and AI and so on.
And finally I went to a few CEOs
including Mastercard's own CEO.
I feel very grateful
that they were absolutely
applauding the content.
And then there's Raja
I think somebody had to call
it and you are doing it.
And so I said, really be able
to endorse the book then.
Because one is, we can have
a secret private conversation
where in fact we know the
backend of this great stuff.
So they agreed and to have
actually given their endorsements
this is the, who is who
of the marketing community
from the practitioner's point of view,
and also from CEOs where
they are actually leveraging,
you know, marketing in their companies
and all kinds of companies.
I feel extremely grateful
for the response I got.
And if I can say just one
quote, which stood out for me
more than anyone else,
this is from the CMO of
General Mills, Ivan Pollard.
His quote, goes something like this.
He says, "This book will
do to our view of marketing
what Copernicus's book did
to our view of the world,
it'll change it forever."
Now Ivan provided the highest compliment
that I could aspire from peer of mine,
am incredibly grateful.
And so far, the response
has been very good.
A lot of people are
uncomfortable saying that,
"Wow, do I want my CEO to see this?
You know, how do I act?"
So that is obviously tension,
but I think it is necessary.
And it's a healthy tension
as best as I see it.
- I couldn't agree more like everybody.
I'm sure you can pick this up on Amazon
and Barnes & Nobles and
all the other things.
Raja, one more time,
the name of the book,
because I encourage everybody
look, everybody who listens to this knows
I don't learn from reading.
So I don't tend to read, but
the people that I allowed
on this podcast talk about books
or people I have a read on them,
which makes me uncomfortably comfortable
to give them this platform.
I'd love everybody in the Vayner nation
to pick up this book if it's hit a chord
or maybe in a lot of
ways creates an intellect
or a black and white or a mathematical
or a different angle to a lot
of the things I believe in.
So Raja, as I leave now, please tell them
the name of the book and thank
you for being on the show.
- Thank you very much.
The name of the book again,
is "Quantum Marketing"
and you know, please
do pick it up and again
I would love to engage
with any one of you.
If you have ideas, that
challenge what I'm saying,
I would love to, you know,
have these conversations.
I'm on Twitter, on
LinkedIn, Raja Rajamannar
and love to do that.
And Gary, thank you so much.
And you know, if I look up to you
as one of those Mavericks and
the absolutely brilliant folks
who disrupted the industry in a way
that nobody could have anticipated.
And I think the first time that we met,
I mentioned this to you saying that,
"Wow," you know,
and I continue that feeling
and I'm so delighted for your support
and look forward to having
more conversations in future.
- Cheers my friend, take care.
- Thank you.
- YouTube watcher what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you,
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode.
Stories, polls more content,
more engagement, more
surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.